good morning believe nation today's
message is fight to be you over you APJ
Abdul Kalam I learned what did I learn
from the youth of 11 million people I
learned
Jefferey youths watch to be unique every
youth wants to be unique that is you the
over you to watch be unique that is you
but the world around that around you is
doing it best day and night to make you
just be everybody else now now the
question is whether you want to be you
are everybody else you you want to be
you not everybody else now in the post
be like everybody else is convenient at
the first glance but not satisfying in
the long vision the challenge there for
my young friends is that you have to
fight the hardest battle you have to
fight the hardest battle which any human
being can ever imagine to fight and
never stop fighting until you arrive at
your destiny you so I love this message
and I feel like I've talked about this
recently on my channel too many
entrepreneurs do things because their
friends want them to do it their parents
want them to do it the rest of their
family want them to do it their culture
their society wants them to do it and
you're only really gonna have a major
impact you're only gonna really have the
success you're looking for you're only
gonna really have the money and the the
love and the atmosphere that you want
when you are doing something that makes
you come alive and you're living your
life instead of what other people want
you to do and I get how that can be hard
sometimes if you are in a family of
lawyers and
ten generation of lawyers and you are
expected to be the next person to be a
lawyer and following that tradition then
it's hard to break free and it takes a
lot of guts to do it but it's gonna take
a lot of guts to chase your dream it's
going to take a lot of guts to have a
big impact it's gonna take a lot of guts
to overcome all the other obstacles that
are come along your path this is just
the first of many to come the key is to
stop caring as much about what other
people are thinking about you and live
your path because it's the right path
for you not the right path for them I
recently brought on Alex who helps me
run this business Toronto dance salsa
and one of the things that I just can't
help doing is seeing more in people
right I believe in people I see
something better in them than what they
see in themselves I can't help it it's
part of what I do and being around me
you're gonna get an injection of believe
it just is going to happen and I
challenge people to think bigger and
step outside their comfort zone and try
to be the best version of themselves and
Alex said hey don't you care what people
think about you when you challenge them
because they may not always be receptive
to it and the short answer is no I don't
really care and it's because I know my
intention is good right and you should
know that your intention is good like
you may not be right it may not be the
right answer
you might make mistakes but if the
intention is good and it's in your heart
then you have to go and do it I don't
know if you can ever completely ignore
the pressures from outsiders from
parents and family from friends I don't
know if that's ever totally possible at
least for me but with practice you get
better at it and better at it and better
at it and it comes from the realization
understanding that they may be coming
from a place of love and a desire to
want to help you out but following that
path is not in your best interest and
the more you get used to exercise in
that muscle the less you're gonna worry
about what other people are thinking and
the more you're gonna play or yourself
so yeah what that guy said so the
question of the day today is how do you
fight to be you leave it in the comments
below I'm gonna join the discussion
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso